>> WE THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO TAKE STOCK OF WHERE WE ARE.
CHRISTOPHER CARR WROTE A
STUNNING GUEST ESSAY ARGUING
THAT THE CONFLICT IS SPIRALING
OUT OF CONTROL.
U.S. POLICYMAKING, HE SAYS, HAS
CONTRIBUTED, SAYING EVEN IF WE
DON'T ACCEPT THE CLAIM THAT THIS
IS THE REASON THE WAR HAPPENED,
IT IS THE REASON THAT IT'S TAKEN
THE KINETIC AND DEADLY FORMAT
HAS.
THE ROLE IN THIS IS NOT PASSIVE
OR INCIDENTAL, WE HAVE GIVEN
UKRAINIANS CAUSE TO BELIEVE THEY
CAN PREVAIL A WAR OF ESCALATION,
THAT MAY ALLOW MORAL AND
POLITICAL OBLIGATION TO STAY THE
COURSE AND MATCH ANY EXCESS.
WELL, GIVEN THAT LEVELHEADED
MORNING, THIS HEADLINE ARRIVED,
36 EXPERTS AGREE SAY TO STAY THE
COURSE IN UKRAINE.
AND OF COURSE, THEY COULDN'T
HELP BUT GET THE SENSE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD THIS LANGUAGE BEFORE.
>> WE ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING
AND WE MUST STAY THE COURSE.
>> MY MESSAGE TODAY IS THAT WE
WILL STAY THE COURSE.
>> OKAY, SO THE MANY BILLIONS IN
WEAPONRY THAT WE ARE SENDING, IS
IT REALLY ABOUT ENSURING A
VICTORY OR IS IT JUST NEEDLESSLY
EXTENDING THE BLOODSHED, AND
ELITE VANITY PROJECT FROM A
FOREIGN POLICY ESTABLISHMENT
THAT HAS BEEN DURING THE LAST
TWO DECADES?
JOINING ME NOW.
OKAY, HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE
HEARD THIS STAY THE COURSE,
VICTORY IS AROUND THE CORNER,
WE'VE GOT THEM ON THE RUN, YOU
KNOW, TAKE YOUR CITY OR YOUR
TOWN.
YOU SURPRISED BY THIS AT THIS
POINT?
>> EVERY TIME I'VE BEEN HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS FROM THE START,
THE TEAM HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
QUESTION THAT IS MOST IMPORTANT,
THE ONE WHICH IS IN WHAT WAY
DOES THIS SERVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, OBVIOUSLY, IT DOES NOT.
IN TERMS OF A TINY SLIVER IN
WASHINGTON AND SOME OF THE
SECURITY STATE TO GET MONEY AND
POWER.
RIGHT AT THE MOMENT THE MARKET
FOR THE WEAPONS DISAPPEARS, AND
LO AND BEHOLD I THINK THE OP-ED
REALLY REFLECTS THE FACT OF HOW
SUPPRESSED THE DEBATE HAS BEEN
BECAUSE IT POINTS TO THINGS LIKE
WE BEEN HERE SINCE 2014, AND
HEAVY WEAPONRY, VERY PROVOCATIVE
GESTURES AND IT'S BEEN AN
ABSENCE OF ANY ATTACK RESOLVED
IT DIPLOMATICALLY.
YES, WE CARE ABOUT THE
UKRAINIANS.
BUT THE JOE BIDEN OF
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
ESCALATING AT SEEMINGLY
DIFFERENTLY, WHICH IS WHAT YOU
DO IF YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT THEM
BUT INSTEAD CARE ABOUT WEAPONS
MANUFACTURING AND THE POWER OF
THE U.S. SECURITY.
>> THEY TALKED ABOUT WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN NEXT.
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I WON'T TELL THEM WHAT THEY
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT DO.
IT APPEARS TO ME AT SOME POINT
ALONG THE LINE THAT WHAT IT
ENTAILS, I DON'T KNOW, BUT IN
THE MEANTIME WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PUT THE UKRAINIANS
IN A POSITION WHERE THEY CAN
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
>> GERMANY AND FRANCE, JUST A
FEW DAYS AGO, URGED RUSSIA TO GO
BACK TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE,
THEY WANT THIS OVER, CLEARLY,
KILLING THE ECONOMY.
AND JOE BIDEN IS STILL
MEANDERING DOWN THIS ROAD, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
SENDING MORE WEAPONS.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE 8.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A NARRATIVE SHIFT OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS THAT IS
NOTABLE, THE MEDIA HAS BARELY
ACKNOWLEDGED THE RUSSIAN
ADVANCES AT ALL.
YOU WOULD THINK THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE VANQUISHED A MUCH MORE
POWERFUL MILITARY.
SO TO ACTUALLY EXPEL THEM TO THE
PREINVASION BORDERS YOU WOULD
NEED A COMMITMENT OVER MANY
YEARS THAT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS AND VERY EXPENSIVE.
YOU CANNOT WIN A WAR ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE WORLD WITHOUT
IT WELL BEYOND THE AMERICANS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ENDURE.
>> YOU CALL THIS FRO